what's your life girl you okay right now
[Laughter]
how was your weekend
what was the weekend my twins great what
did I do
all right a dance convention you went to
dance convention I'm gonna ask you about
some pictures we saw of you and a
certain man from your show his name is
Tyler uh what you guys got that drink
huh yeah I have a jerk yeah I had some
drink drinks this week okay all right
you and Tyler hung out we saw the photos
how did it go I have a great time okay
yeah this is the moment it's happening I
know yeah
it's so weird how people know where I
live now it's great um but yeah we
definitely hung out and talked about
everything and I know nobody will
believe me just hanging out and actually
talking but yeah it was good to be able
to catch up we have a lot to talk a lot
to talk about and to just I believe you
look you had your fantasy suite it was
yeah what like that it was like yeah
okay weird to talk about right now yeah
okay what did you guys decide about your
next steps or your future
are you there soon as as what we've been
saying okay we are trying to figure out
where this like how we feel I've said to
you to a lot of like I saw feelings but
I'm also single and he's single and I
want to keep my options open and he can
keep his options open and I'm just
looking forward to whatever
opportunities come for me next and
that's what I'm focused on could one of
those opportunities be Dancing with the
Stars well that would be really cool you
kill it girl Chris Harrison told me he
thought you could like win the whole
thing
oh if that was a possibility for me I
would be so competitive and that Miraval
would be mine but that is not the case
right now but I would love to be able to
do that well in terms of next steps for
Tyler I did ask you how would you feel
about him being the bachelor what I want
to know after you hung out with him is
do you think he is ready to be the
bachelor is he looking for something
serious uh I I don't know where he's at
with with wanting to be the bachelor I I
think he has his options open as well
and if the bachelor it's one of those
options then like I said I would support
him if that's what he wants to do okay
um I gotta ask you about one other man
Jed was seen like in some comments about
you not-so-nice comments about you how
did you feel about that do you think he
really is sorry for the things that he
did I do think that he's sorry this not
only hurt me and him but his family and
and everyone and but why I like those
comments I don't know why he like why he
liked this comment I mean stuff about
you sleeping with other people and yeah
I don't I don't know why he's like those
comments I mean I think there's there's
always when you're hurt because he's
hurt - you want to justify things and
maybe that's that was just a way for him
to see it in a way that that explains
some of his hurt yeah but you know I
think we all know what show Iran and my
dating relationships were very out in
the open and everybody knew what they
were yeah a part of and well speaking of
another show you're on bachelor in
paradise
yeah so excited to watch Demi share her
story in her journey how powerful was
that for you as her good friend I'm so
proud of Demi yeah I am proud of just
how strong of a woman that she is and
how she is so brave to be able to kind
of step
to the unknown that bachelor The
Bachelor franchise has never really put
on display and that she is being so
courageous
to be tell her truth yeah and to to show
all different sides of who she is and in
what she believes love is and to be able
to explore that and I am glad that I was
able to be a part of that conversation
conversation and show my support and
love for her because I am supportive of
whatever makes Demi happy well girl
you're single mhm anybody you want to
slide into your DMS you know I I am
single and people slide into my deems
that they want to but I just got out of
an engagement and dating 30 men that's
really not my sole focus right now I'm
working on Hannah and loving Hannah and
so you know if that means going to have
a drink again with somebody else then
I'm all for it
you